Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab is supported by swell investing and impact investing platform.
Invest in high growth companies that are solving today's biggest challenges like
clean water disease eradication, renewable energy.
Claim your $50 bonus to swell investing.com/radio lab.
Hey wait, you're listening.
[inaudible]
listening to radio lab radio lab
from W n.
Y. S. E. N. P. E. R. Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab podcast and today on the podcast we're going to talk about
containers. Well, no. Yeah, why not? Well, because it's bigger than containers.
It's categories because with like the boring way as the borough word for design.
Oh, boring taxonomy. Can we say this? You could, yes.
This is a story about what goes where and what doesn't go there and what should
go there. If you were only smarter about it, just kind of measure you around.
Yeah, that's, that's what I want to talk about.
I say you have a story to tell us, right? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So you tell us your story. Set it up for us like, well,
let's start back in 1993 with two customs attorney, Sherry Sanger,
and my name is Andy Singer, singer and singer, singer, and saying,
and one day the two of them are looking at this customs book called the
harmonized tariff schedule. What was it called again? The Harman. What?
Harmonized tariff. You almost harmonized the harmonized tariff.
It's this huge book chock full of customs classifications,
products, milk products, vegetables,
and it's got everything in it and literally thousands of provisions.
They're flipping through this big book
and what they noticed that day
is that in this book were the following words,
representing only human beings.
They saw this fateful phrase right next to the word dog. Under the harmonize.
A doll was something that represented only a human being.
They don't represent it. A human being only a human being.
It could not be any other creature, but a human being. So Barbie is a doll,
right? But here's the thing, in this big book right next to dolls,
it's this whole other category called toys, toys,
which covers things like monsters, robots, angels.
Basically anything that isn't only representing a human to the dolls are human
and the toys are not human. Yeah.
And where it gets weird is that these two categories were being taxed
differently. How, how differently?
12% for dolls and 6.8% for toys. Really.
So getting a Barbie doll into the country,
it would be more expensive than like importing a transformer or something. Yeah.
Why? I assume it was because, uh, there was a domestic industry,
a domestic doll industry that, um, wanted and needed protection.
Do you think there was a, a powerful doll lobby
and you know, you got these two categories,
you've got these two ladies and they have a client called marvel comics,
marvel con. This is the home of men with capes and super powers. Yes.
And beautiful boots. Tights. Marvel. Yes. What about marvel? Well,
marvel comics has this universe of action figures coming into our reports as
adults weight,
all their action figures were being classified as though everything was a doll.
Yeah. At 12% rate of duty and cheering.
Indie realized that there's a huge opportunity here.
If they can convince the government to remove the marvel action heroes from the
human ear Barbie doll category and push them into the robot de mini toy
category, they can save a huge amount of money.
Lisa dollars, tens of thousands of maybe hundreds of dollars. We'll do how much?
Thousands of dollars.
She's 50 a million dollars and then I'm more than a million dollars cause they
wouldn't be taxed as high. This is, this is about more than just business.
This is about more than Saturday morning cartoons.
This is about what it means to be a human, what you, we'll think about it.
They have to convince government officials that under US law,
these characters are not considered human
[inaudible].
That's definitely really to share you in Indy headed to customs,
customs headquarters in d c with a giant bag full of superheroes.
We actually went down there. We had a meeting, we brought samples, uh,
of all the items and you've got action figures. You mean we did,
we had 60 or 80 figures and one by one we tried to convince them,
um, that these figures do not represent human being.
And believe it or not,
this meeting ended up in a series of court cases that went on for 10 years,
10 years. Cause we got really complicated and interesting.
So when they got to Marvel's crown tool, the x men,
they didn't even read the stories.
Sherry and I were not familiar with comic books sharing what they should have
because it's a great story.
I mean the story of x man is kind of about the next phase of human evolution.
Regular parents having regular kids,
but some of these kids around their awkward teen years,
you start to develop these strange mutant powers.
So the story is humans who mutate out.
Well that's what makes this so legally tricky. I mean,
are these characters still human or have they evolved somehow out of humanness
into something entirely different? Now,
the government says that all of the imported action figures,
they are representations. Human beings, if they have things like a head,
a mouth, eyes, nose,
hair, arms, torso, breasts,
muscles. If you look at at, at any of these guys, cyclops,
he has all the basic elements that are the government's definition of a human
being. And what do you say? Well, eventually to make their point,
sharing an indie pulled out of gluten free guide.
X-Men fans might know as pieced. We can look at this
one early on. Well, he's called beast. Even a,
he has two arms. He has two legs. Yeah.
Does have the with Roberts beast in the x men,
uh, storyline. He's a pretty, he's a pretty like a sophisticated guys.
They're like, he's, he's a thoughtful intellectual. Am I right? Like, yeah,
you would be the first x men to keep trace glasses. He quoted Shakespeare,
he quote Shakespeare, Shakespeare
show his condition and Bennett England. Now a bad,
we'll count that manhood's cheap.
So don't you think that puts them well down the human's sort of a bell curve?
Well in this case,
our argument would be is human beings do not have blue skin.
The judge agreed [inaudible] that's pretty, that's there. There are,
there are human beings with blueish skin.
You should know that there's a water to, uh,
fit into the mold of what we customarily know as Yeoman. That's Joe Leibman.
He worked on the case for the government side.
He has aspects that perhaps are closer to the monster,
but it gets trickier. Take the most popular acts, man,
Wolverine, he's got muscular arms and legs. Uh,
he puts on a coat and a flannel shirt and he's a logger. Sure, but the eyes,
they just didn't look human. And that's what our basic gun,
the clause and the clause metal clause
in the story, a mad scientist implanted them in his arms under his skin.
But that just means he's a guy who had a little augmentation now. Well,
he's developed something we don't know to actually exist.
That does not mean that it might not exist in future humans in a world that we
have not yet seen. Joe's basic point is don't rule it out.
He pointed to this runner, Oscar Pistorius,
they call him the blade runner. The world's fastest man on no legs,
double amputee runner from South Africa who wears prosthetic legs that some
people claim actually increases speed
saying his prosthetics had more spring than human legs.
And some people say he should be disqualified from competing against equal body
humans.
The body that governs track and field
banned him from competition. We'll forget about augmentation.
What if we're just talking mutation? I mean,
as a human we have about 20,000 genes and if one of them just gives you Claus,
that doesn't mean that the other 19,000, 999 genes.
Alright, keeping you pretty much in the human classification.
I S I studied, um,
my undergraduate degree is in microbiology and biochemistry.
So I know that we have mutations wing on antibody constantly.
We're all mutants in common language. And in science fiction,
when you use the word mutant,
she says, you mean something or someone that's disfigured.
The helium that's no longer like us. So colloquially,
if marvel calls the X-men Mutans, then they're not human.
On the Wolverine case. Did you win or lose? We won. We won.
[inaudible]
which, well, how do you feel about this? Like
I don't know. I, I'm kind of seeing red.
No, but seriously, here's the thing. In the x-men universe,
all the x men are trying to do is fit into our world. I don't want to hurt you,
Eric. I never get to feel like a human being the truth.
Marvel comics has created this world where mutans want to be treated like humans
and the government is persecuting them as monsters. But in the real world,
it's exactly the opposite.
You got marvels saying they're monsters and you've got the government saying,
no. Let them be human. In the x-men universe,
humans are very often out to get the mutants or dismissive,
the Mutans fearful of the mutants, liquidating them, experimenting on them.
First of all, tell us who you are. I am Bryan singer. I'm a filmmaker.
Bryan directed a bunch of the x men movies, x men, one x-men, two x men United,
and he says,
all the movies at their heart are parables about living in a world where you
don't fit. You're not the right
category. In fact,
the first x men filled me direct u s government fears meeting so much that this
US senator puts forward legislation called the mutant registration act.
Newton's are very real and they are among us.
We must know who they are.
And above all we must know what they can do.
That us them conflict is key to the entire saga.
Well, yeah,
and that's no coincidence that it was born during the height of the civil rights
movement. So this is like, so this is modeled then on a civil and on,
on a moment in in world history where people were trying to figure out how to
either get along or not get along. Yeah, absolutely.
This tension plays out within the mutans themselves. Well, you have two groups,
the x men who choose to take the stance to defend a world that hates and fears
them don't give up on the marriage. Then you've got this other group
of mutants led by Magneto or what are you having to do, Charles?
And he doesn't have faith that humanity's ever going to embrace mutans.
We are the fear Church House. Not Them. I know matter.
He saw that what happens when you're different is you get rounded up,
experimented them, eliminate and your guests.
It's interesting to hear you describe that because when I,
when I walked out of the, the most recent movie,
I felt such a strong,
maybe a stronger connection with magneto after you saw what he went through.
Yeah. You see the,
the intimate victimization of him and you root for him because he's ultimately
facing a monster. And when he was making these movies,
he had that monster of intolerance and prejudice on his mind.
And it was actually pretty personal to him. Oh,
there's a photo album my family has. And um, it's, it starts in the 20s.
And I was looking through it and I recognize the lineage.
And then there were a few pages of just these portraits of different people.
I didn't know who they were. And I said to my dad, I'm like,
who are these people? And my dad goes, they're all gone.
They're the ones that are gone from Poland.
They're just all gone. They're there, they're erased. There's no records,
there's no property, there's no nothing. So he doesn't even know their name.
Nope.
We just know that there are people that were part of the neighborhood and the
family, uh,
in the 30s that never left Poland like my grandparents did and,
and disappeared. Well,
and I know this sounds pretty heavy for a comic book,
but over the years the x men have been a stand in for first the civil rights
movement of the 60s and most recently the story works as an allegory for gay
rights. In fact, the next men too,
we actually had a coming out scene in the scene. This kid Bobby Drake,
he's hiding some of the x men in his parent's house and then his parents come
home and find him with these strangers to be at school. Bobby,
who is this guy and he is forced basically to show his parents that he's a
mutant. There's something I need to tell you.
So everyone takes a seat in the living room and Bobby using his special mutant
powers, he freezes a Little Cup of coffee.
[inaudible]
and the parents react in panic and the mother actually says, have you tried
not being a mutant? Really like it's a choice.
[inaudible] we have to get to it. We have to find it.
Like what the ultimate legal just disposition of this case was. Yeah.
So did they,
did they in the end say that these characters were human or did they perpetuate
this retail bigotry?
I can say that they were non-humans you guys really want to know. Yeah, we are.
We have to know. We have to come on. Yeah, exactly. Tell us
non-humans. Ah, seriously.
Eventually the judge ruled that all marvel heroes,
not just the x men are not human.
So Sherry an indie one, we're not rights
the, when you're, when you're having your nice meal after the,
after the case and you don't feel that at all,
that you have just robbed humanity from the whole population.
We had absolutely no guilt at all. Like
none.
[inaudible]
wow. Well, thank you. I can, you're welcome chat.
That would be [inaudible] Kinda Raja. I report to run this story.
We also had a fine producer, Matthew Kielty,
who is just left us for greener pastures. Thank you, Matt.
I remember Krulwich and I am [inaudible] and thanks for listening.